really really briefly show you the other
way of proving this
uh it's always good to have more than
one way to approach things um
not only does it mean you can use either
but you can also use them to verify each
other in case it's not like a show
but it's like a find something right you
can use both ways and if you get the
same thing on both then
that's a pretty got a pretty good chance
to do that right
now uh you might look at this and it
talks about distance between the roots
right
now if i call it k that distance you can
immediately make some statements about
the roots right so for instance um you
might say let the roots be
now traditionally we would call them
after beta right because there's two
but since i know that they are k units
apart
i don't have to call them completely
separate variables i can call them alpha
and will the other one be
alpha plus k right because that's the
distance between the roots that's what
i'm defining it as
okay so now that i've got this i can
start to establish some things with it
so for instance
if you go sum of roots
okay the sum of roots is two alpha plus
k
right and
what is the sum of the roots equal to
it's um minus b
on a right which is just minus b
uh and likewise if you take the product
you're going to have alpha squared
plus alpha k and that's just equal to c
okay now um keeping that in mind how are
you going to use that right
well i want to now i've worked out this
part and i want to go up to
get that distance d in terms of all of
this okay
so how do i do that well again i'm going
to say the
axis of symmetry right it's just halfway
between the roots
right so it's halfway between here and
here it's just half of this
right does that make sense so if i want
to um
or especially all in terms of alphas
because that's what i've got here right
i'm going to have two alpha plus k
on two so that's alpha plus
k on two right and i can take that and i
can sum it into my original equation
that'll give me
the y coordinate of the vertex right
uh so what are we gonna get we're gonna
get y equals
that's x squared plus
um now instead of saying b
i'm going to get it all in terms of
alphas okay so this is going to become a
minus
i think yeah minus 62
alpha plus okay
let's see plus
that's what i've worked out to be c okay
i've got that in this line here
okay now this is what makes this
approach longer than the previous
approach
you've got a bit of algebraic sort of
wrangling to do okay but sometimes
depending on the kind of question they
give you this approach will be the only
one that works the previous one which is
nice and neat
just won't be sufficient okay so once
you sort out all of your um
all of your expansion you can see
there's going to be a lot of like terms
that cancel out okay where you end up is
just
well yeah there's a lot of cancelling
all the alphas actually cancel okay so
there's like two or three lines here you
just have to be a little careful but you
can see like say for instance two alpha
and k on 2 minus 2 alpha
count 2. so what you're left with 2's
cancel that's minus alpha k
and there's one over there so you can
see how all of the alphas will disappear
but this statement in itself right means
that i can say
d is the absolute value of that
right and because i already know k
squared is positive
i can get rid of um i'll get rid of this
actually
okay because that's that's what takes
care of the absolute value whether it be
negative and that kind of thing
uh sorry i shouldn't say okay squared
all right and that's already the
statement i'm already there
right so d at this point is proportional
to k
squared okay so as i've written it it
looks about the same length as the other
one but that's because i've skipped a
bit of algebraic expansion here okay
but this is a it's neat because it's
using quite a different
you know theoretical approach that's why
it will work in different situations
okay